hey guys I'm Hallie Stevens and we're
here in New York City with Constance
whoo I do want to talk to you a little
bit about crazy rich Asians everyone is
buzzing about a sequel the second and
third books do introduce a bunch of new
characters so who would you love to see
join the cast oh my gosh I don't know
you know I love santaros work I think
she's phenomenal I Love Lucy Liu she's
kind of an icon to me so I don't know
any of these Asian American women like
like Margaret Cho who have been pioneers
sort of in representation and have sort
of paved the way for movies like crazy
rich Asians love to get to work with
people like that et is partnered with
American Express to celebrate their peut
Planet feature feature with American
Express and I've partnered with them
because it's something that I think I
could have really used when I first
started out in my career I would have
big purchases that I thought I needed to
make that work investments in my career
like getting headshots done paying that
all at once sometimes would feel a
little daunting it gives you control and
flexibility to pay for things your own
way
before you got your big acting break
what were you doing to pay your bills I
was waitressing my waitress here in New
York City for like ten years any like
crazy waitressing stories one time I
waited on Oprah and I accidentally
spilled her water
I was mortified she was totally cool she
hardly even noticed I was like have you
met Oprah yet aside from that moment yes
I have very very briefly did you remind
her of this story you think I'm gonna
remind her that I spilled her water I
want to make a good impression you know
like my opportunity for a clean slate
well you might hear that now but I think
it's great to learn more head over to
American Express com / peut planet